well tell us about it first of all fresh
wine but the eighth a contemporary art
show is all it's pretty much a process
of discovery we bring a world of art to
Hong Kong
you know the contemporary art scene here
in Hong Kong has had been heavily
dominated by Chinese contemporary
property over the last thirty years so
it's an opportunity for collectors and
also hires in Hong Kong to see our work
that they wouldn't typically see 100 or
so galleries and one of the features of
the show is we do encourage the
participation of artists buying
something you actually have the
connection between what you do did it
exactly and you know for the collector
and sort of furthermore sort of
passionate amongst the buyer community
you know understanding the work and the
context the worker you know it's is
important to them yeah absolutely
okay as an alternative or alternative
investment here it's very very difficult
so what would you be your tip to
somebody who's seeking to make well
contemporary art an investment choice
well I think from my own experience buy
because you like it
number one number two I think a critical
factor is you know asking the right
questions and of course well asking the
right questions about the artists you
know how long have they been working
where they've been exhibiting who
collects their workers as an example you
know there's a lot of fluff in this
industry so you know in order to make
informed buying decision you really have
to get in and ask some questions of of
either the gallery who is obviously the
salesman or the artist to be present
what are we talking about in terms of
prices here though well what what we've
done is we we're in the mid market and
what that really means is anywhere from
25,000 Hong Kong dollars up to four or
five hundred thousand dollars and that
covers the range of artists who are
younger in terms let's have a look at
some of the mark here let's look at
mother and daughter for instance and
this is a bit of work four and a half
thousand US dollars here yeah is it by
and well why that price yeah this was an
interesting this was an interesting
artist from Vietnam and it was a it was
a situation which we encountered the
last show a visit of the show walked
into the organizers office and said I've
seen this artwork on the show website my
wife likes it where is it
and we're long down the well and it was
and it was a connection that we
connection that we made for them Andy
Warhol there we go
this is a screen print here I think it's
yeah screen print yeah 24 and a half
yeah so you got the other side yeah
you're moving you're moving a little bit
more up the scale and I definitely even
though it's a small edition screen print
it does represent an investment class
work sentiment is about Chinese artists
I think you Shang Chen he is established
you know what makes him interesting is
like a number of artists that grew up
formative years during the Cultural
Revolution and that's very much
reflected through the character of his
work and visually the traditions of
China but also the the the influence or
the growing influence of women in China
I do like this one here but it does it
is reflected in the price nearly a
hundred and sixty thousand US dollars
and it's a ashamed face one by the
Chapman Chapman brothers are two artists
two British artists actually and it's an
interesting work in that it was
originally the base of the work is
actually a Victorian portrait which they
in 2007 did a series of works with a
defaced the work and created in a
contemporary context but in an
interesting image